Hello everyone, this is Frank Defratis, and welcome to another week of HoloTalk for the week of May 21st, 2000.
Welcome back.
I was away for a number of weeks.
Didn't have a chance to update the show.
In fact, uh was only back here in the studio maybe about a few days out of three weeks, uh on the road doing different things, also down Washington, DC with the Smithsonian.
So we're back here.
It's great to be back.
Great to have another Holo Talk up and uh hopefully uh usually uh HoloTalk ends Memorial Day and is off the summer from Memorial Day through Labor Day, but I'm hoping to maybe be able to uh continue Holo Talk through the summer.
What what do you think?
Would you like to hear Hollow Talk through the summer?
Send me an email and let me know.
And instead of going off the air memorial day, what we'll do is just continue uh producing shows throughout the summer.
I'm going to try and get Michelle Roy in here this week, as many of you are aware.
Michelle was with me down at the Smithsonian, uh at the Hershawn specifically, and uh we'd like to get her in the studio and do a show on uh both of our feelings on what it was like to present holography uh at an art venue.
Uh my background with lasers and holography is with science and technology, so it's always interesting when I have the opportunity of going in and doing presentations for people who have an artistic interest in holography as well.
And there are differences, and we'd like to uh do a show to tell you what some of those differences are, some observations we've made and where we think uh holography strong points are with uh both it it's uh science and technology uh background and all it's also its artistic background as well.
Our guest this week is Dars Vila, and I would like to point out before you listen to the show that this was recorded a couple weeks ago before we started out on our uh road trips, and I haven't had a chance of getting the show up.
It's going up now.
The only thing is Doris mentions going away to Germany to do some work, and when you hear that you'll be under the impression that she's leaving for Germany when in actuality this is recorded earlier and she's back from Germany now.
So keep that in mind when you're listening to the interview.
So welcome back again and uh let's move on to the interview with Daris Veel.
If you'd like to hear Hull Talk continue through the summer, please send me an email.
Let me know if I get enough emails to tell me that they'd like to uh that you'd like to hear the shows, I'll continue to do them.
If not, then we'll say adios and see you in the uh s in the fall.
So here's the interview with Doris Vila.
Thanks for tuning in and see you next week.
Hi, Frank.
Hello, Doris, how are you?
Fine.
I want to just switch to the other phone so I can speak a little bit more freely.
How are you?
I'm doing good.
Good.
Give me a sec.
Okay.
Hi.
Well that sounds good.
That sounds okay to you?
Yeah, it's a different sound than the other phone, but I think it'll work okay.
Good.
You know, I was on your website and I've been following a lot of your work through the different publications over the years, like through Holosphere and Wavefront and some of the other ones.
And to tell you the truth, after being on your website and seeing all the things that you've done, I'm in a loss at where to even start with you.
Well, that is really sweet.
I'm very honored.
Yeah.
I I've been busy.
When did you get started in holography?
I started in nineteen seventy-nine.
And in a way I kind of date how I started much earlier than that from um having done work with Littman photography, recreating Littman photographs in provincial Mexico.
Was your background in photography and videography?
Um y actually I started drawing.
Um a classic artist background.
Mm-hmm.
And um yeah, that that was how I got started.
What moved you on to holography?
Well, um uh when I was living and working at the University of Veracruz in Mexico, I started working with stereo photography.
Okay.
And a lot of print making alternative techniques where we would improvise our own technology.
And we'd melt build our own graphic arts cameras, getting the lenses ground at the local optician and mix up our own photo filtering emulsions starting to sound familiar.
You were involved with a lot of the technology as well.
Yeah, I've always believed that artists have more um can make a much more interesting statement with a medium if they get their hands in the middle of it.
Mm-hmm.
Well you you find excuse me, even in the field of philography that a lot of artists try to stay away from the technology end of it.
Well, it can be distracting and I really understand and respect artists that want to avoid getting so tech heavy that they lose sight of like a mental and emotional message that they want to communicate.
Yeah.
I really understand it.
It just with my work and the way I work, I I need to be shifting hats all the time.
Mm-hmm.
See, I couldn't have made those big holograms without being able to do it myself.
I was like directly intervening with the plate all the time.
So I needed to understand what diffraction efficiencies had to be in order to get that big and operate with a coherence length, use the spherical aberration as a way to make stories play out at different positions rather than different moments and time.
Is there a reason why you've you chose to do I would say I would imagine most, if not all of your work is uh white light transmission holograms.
Is there a reason for that?
Well, the d mostly 'cause the transmission hologram allowed me to break scale.
I've done some color work and reflection, and in fact one of the biggest compliments I've gotten is, my God, your reflection colors look like your transmission colors because I really got into the tech and how to narrow the band of reconstruction.
You know, what other a lot of other people have done in in reflection, but just have been able to tune it to suit and look and feel that my work already has.
What are some of the projects that you would look back on and want to tell to the listeners about?
Um, gee.
All of them, right?
Yeah, of course.
Which they can see at your website and we do have a link to Doris's uh website right on the Holo Talk page.
So if you go back on the Holo Talk page and click on the link, it will take you right over to her website which is just loaded loaded with years worth of uh work and papers and research papers and everything.
Yeah, I you know, it's it's really interesting because the um one of the greatest things for me about being involved in holography has been the number of people, the range of people I've been able to meet and the kinds of cross discipline jumping I've been able to do just uh really gives a lot of room um for my imagination.
All kinds of technical imagination as as well as aesthetic.
Yeah, I I I guess one of the things that has been really uh fruitful for me in recent years has been combining holography with other electronic media.
And it started with a piece in ninety two that I was able to do in Germany where I had a hologram of fire in a store window.
Oh yeah.
And was illuminating it with the live signal of the feet of people passing by.
So if they walked by you they saw their own feet at eye level.
Mm-hmm.
And they were walking through the flames, which was of course um the holographic flames which could never burn them, but a metaphor for passing through a trial of fire or a proof of purity and here they were just shopper.
Wow.
And so I I like that a lot and that gave me a lot of jumping off territory.
Um for mixing projected imagery.
When you would mix the media, did you find that you did that more because you felt there were limitations in holography and you were able to move beyond those limitations by mixing other media in?
Yes, very much so.
I mean the presence of the three dimensions of holography made me crave the the fourth time.
So I really wanted to be able to uh make that happen and and breathe a little life into the the three dimensional form of holography.
You've been teaching as well in the past.
Uh do you still run workshops and things now in New York?
Well I d I haven't had any requests for that.
Uh every so often I'm asked to lecture at a school, which I I love to do that.
I'm really I get to indulge my ham side of myself by standing up in front of students and talking to them.
Mm-hmm.
And and I one of the things that I I have happiest about is that I've been able to get a sense of humor, if I can say that to infuse my work because I've had a kind of teasing relationship with science.
Science is great, but it just doesn't go quite far enough.
Well I like a sense of humor glad to hear it.
So yeah, that's um so I like talking to groups about that, but I um I'm not getting a lot of requests for holographic type teaching right now.
Wow.
I find that surprising in New York City.
I am too.
You know?
Well, you know, we also have a couple of very talented people well that are you know, open to Dan Schweitzer's teaching at uh uh one school and running his teaching as part of his practice and goes after that more aggressively.
I'm getting more offers for projects and shows, m many of them overseas.
Yeah.
Um what's with that?
Well, you know, what are you gonna say?
You know?
You know, y I I know they used to say a prophet is never recognized in their own land, but I think a prophet is never turned in a one's own land, you know.
I don't understand.
I just was I'm I'm going to Germany in fact on Friday to finish a a major project with children's interactive theater.
Well, I know we should always have a global outlook on everything, but I I always feel that we should take more pride in people within the United States that are doing great work and we don't.
Well, one of the things that that happens in New York particularly is the the art world is uh driving force and the art world is believe it or not, somewhat conservative in terms of media.
And so there was a certain point at which I decided that I was going to keep making work but I was not going to try to show it in the traditional gallery settings.
And once you try to you break out of that mold, even though supposedly the avant garde is always testing limits, you find that you really have to look to people that respect the cultural tradition.
And in the States it's the art world is still quite market driven.
Mhm.
Mm-hmm.
So you just have to say, okay, so who's interested?
I am really working very hard on getting more things going here in the coming year.
How do you feel women are represented in floggers for as people working in the field compared to other uh ventures?
Yes, yes, with a little little tiny butt attached to it.
Okay.
Um, in terms of women artists and male artists, I think there's a nice fifty fifty blend.
Um but the women uh in the in the t raw technical and commercial fields it's dominated by men again.
Yeah.
Um, but um even among the artists, if you were to say, Okay, who has or have had their own labs, the women normally use other people's facilities.
That's why I say yes but I mean I think uh if you're um it's really tough to make gender generalization.
Yeah.
But the women often though have had really innovative use of holography in space so that they will take and do something with the hologram in the environment it's shown in or a context for it.
That the men have more gone for a classic approach.
Mm-hmm.
And like I said, I'm real cautious about generalizing that I can think of some real notable exceptions on both sides of the fence.
But um yeah, I think look, women have um have have uh well they may have not been empowered to invest in the the tech so much, certainly in terms of taking aesthetic risks within right out there, if not at the edge.
Yeah.
I have a lot of admiration for that.
I've been uh speaking with someone at S P I E um very sorry I can't remember their name right now, but our emails have been going back and forth.
They just started a group uh women in optics.
And they're very interested in the holography programs that I put together, especially with the shoebox holography that uses uh little diode lasers to create holograms.
So we're looking to uh get a few programs started uh at the educational level to uh show uh female school students uh what's available, not just with holography, but with lasers and photonics in general.
Well that sounds just terrific for me.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I mean let me know if I can be of any help.
Oh absolutely, yes.
Yeah, absolutely.
You know, I'm in the freelance mode, I'm always interested in cooking up schemes.
Yeah.
That's great.
Now you have your own facilities, right?
Yes, I have um I have a basement, uh twelve hundred square foot basement with two five foot by ten foot isolation tables.
Next time c you come to New York, please come by.
Yes.
Yes, I'm going to do that.
When you when are you coming back from Germany?
Uh I'll be back May first.
Oh, okay.
So And I'm actually gonna be showing holograms in Mexico opening the first of June.
I'm going back to that same place that I used to work.
Why don't you give some information to the 'cause you know in the net we have people that listen from Germany as well.
So why don't you uh give a little information about your uh work that you're going over for in Germany and also the Mexican uh show as well.
Great.
Yeah, the the um Project in Germany is an interactive children's theater installation at Animax in Bonn, which is uh an experimental media art group.
And they have a interesting space, part of a cinoplex.
Mm-hmm.
So they're you know, you can imagine twelve theaters and a cinaplex, eleven of them are showing movies and the twelfth one is having this this stage where the children walk into a room and on either side of them are these uh ten foot high by thirteen feet long screens.
They're like pages of a book, three on each side of them, semi transparent.
Mm-hmm.
And the the are basically walk into their bookship and as a group their interactions are registered and they pick their way to a journey to a place and they look for these figures which are made up all of triangles and as soon as they act together, these triangles swarm around them in real time animation, reflecting their the group dynamic of the triangles swarming and flocking in the same way that they move.
So it's very interesting on a number of levels.
And it just drives me nuts that you don't see anything like that here.
Well I hope to be getting a version that can run here.
Yeah.
Not maybe not quite so extravagant in the physical but uh but certainly with all the computer animation we can do that.
And I'm calling it um pseudograms or two and a half D because it's basically two D information but it's being projected onto these layered screens which as they move flying goodness long, graceful motion as the kids make their way through their adventure.
And uh and there's some sort of uh quadright three D in the forming of the triangle.
It's really great.
They they scream a l a vowel and these figures, you know, could be a monster or a bat or a shark made up out of triangles and they go bee and it flies apart.
It's great.
And it's a real interesting I think um because getting a group to work together as a team is the metaphor we're going towards in this century because we've come out of very hierarchical path.
We're coming to work as play, play is work.
Exactly.
And the team approach where leadership functions are still there but they rotate in a much different way.
And consensus is the way to make a decision rather than arbitrary obeying.
I I think this is gonna be and especially if you think of the historical implications of asking German children to work as a group.
Mm the shifting leadership roles this is a very, very big Oh yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, I see that.
So it's it's a it's a riot.
And so you can link to there's a shockwave s sample of what her game looks like on my website.
Um and That's a nice website.
Do you do that yourself?
Why thank you.
Yes, I did with the help of a student intern sure.
Those graphics are mine and all those uh little animation clips.
Yeah, I was all over that today.
Oh good.
Good.
Yeah, it's big fun.
I've had a great time doing it.
And um yeah, and the w the web has just been such a resource for us.
I I've believed since I got involved with philography that we were headed towards an age of energy and information.
Mm-hmm.
And the web just proves it.
Yeah.
Every time.
And very useful to me.
Right now I have posted just for my working colleagues for a site which is is private but allows them to see the storyboards for the improvements that we're making to the game that I'm going over there to line.
Yeah, that's that's a nice um aspect of the web as well for collaboration, you know, across distances.
You know, work collaboration.
Yeah.
And then what's coming up in Mexico?
Well, Mexico is oh actually let me see if I can find the site for you for that, but it's um i in Veracruz, Mexico, every year for the last nine years, uh Professor Miguel Sanat of the University of Veracruz has hosted what he calls uh June the month of photography and it's a statewide series of exhibitions.
Last year there were twenty eight shows around the state of photography from historic figures um to contemporary.
And he invited me to be the honored guest this year.
So um I will be showing a holographic installation of three large panels and um and and several smaller works and some projections.
And what is the turnout for these the events that you do overseas.
Do you find out that it's uh pretty well packed?
Well it depends on the place.
When I'm uh i if you're part of a festival in Berlin man you can't keep 'em out of the door and uh uh in some of the smaller places it's not so large but you w you find that the fall it's a very different attitude there to art you you find people that see your work and three, four, five years later they come back to you say, I saw your work and I want you to come and do something now.
Whereas in this country we're also you know, found by fifteen minutes of same conscious that if you don't you know if you don't close it right there.
That's right.
It's gotten you and they've moved on.
Yeah.
Whereas uh i I've had people invite me to a festival where they bought me over and sponsor an installation and they say, Oh, we wanted to do this since you know.
Yeah, I was thinking about the imagery that you were talking about with your installation in Germany and I was thinking if that were done here.
I don't think you could do that without including burgers and fries somehow in that, you know what I mean?
I'm telling you, it's a very different thing.
Yeah very different thing.
But I'm working on some possibilities too.
I mean as as computers get faster and more portable.
You want to get your lab up and running in New York now or is it up and running now?
Well, you know, all the physical equipment is there unfortunately at the moment my laser's down as I told you and this is why I've been talking with you about your diode lasers, I'm very excited about that possibility.
I have two big fat lasers and um, you know, both of them need new tubes and we're talking about thousands of dollars to replace it.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I think those days are coming to a close.
Well, you know, that would be nice.
I've never thought it it just never made sense to me that it should be so painful to work for h with holography.
It's been a very arduous kind of medium to pursue.
Mm-hmm.
And I really believe it had to get simpler.
Your work is beautiful.
The the only time I've had a chance to see your work was at the Museum of Philography in New York.
You do very abstract work and just the way that the layers are on there and how the motion and how things interact with one another as you move around the holograms is phenomenal.
Oh thanks.
Yeah, I like to think of them as stories that are played out in space as well as time.
So that the physical position of the viewer forces them or allows them to make their own discovery sequence.
And that's what makes it possible for them to um weave a story out of a framework of possibilities.
Mm and that's where my teasing relationship with science has come in.
I I started out in uh eighty eight making things no, eighty seven, making things where it was uh charts, maps and diagrams of pseudo scientific phenomena.
So it was a chart of the space time sex money continuum.
You know, because space and time are one thing, but we know sex and money fit in there somewhere too.
Space and time I have a lot of.
Yeah.
Sex and money I don't know.
You know, y you hear what I'm saying.
But maybe if you had more money you'd have more time.
Yeah.
And then you never know.
And if I had more space I'd have more sex.
That could be that could be.
I don't know.
I I just I just say Einstein was partly right.
And some of the others were the diagnosis of an existential headache.
Mm and uh the overview of the free guilt economy.
There was he said and she said.
So they both are facing panels.
So the when the observer stands between them they have to look or listen to one parent or the other.
They're basically the observer child in between the two.
So you can see that the physical um presence or movement of the person in the space makes a big difference in terms of playing out a story.
Which is what I I think we do with our lives.
It amazes me how artists minds work because basically what my brain thinks about is resistors and transistors and chips and how to get diodes to work and how to do this the technical end of it and um it's a fascinating just to listen to what people would do with the technology.
I mean I have creative thought, but nothing like what you're describing.
Well, I think creativity has uh a million billion forms.
I think we're we're all the time creating.
Yeah.
Trying to make sense out of our lives in the world.
And having some fun with it.
Yeah.
Any new projects that you're planning on in the future, something with the at the Center for the Holographic Arts.
Well, I have a residency there now and we're in the process of shooting.
I'm actually uh making uh a new piece of them which will be the uh newest holographic piece in a while.
So I'm I'm really thrilled about that.
I'm kinda delighted with the concept and that's gonna be very exciting.
Um just uh yeah I'm looking forward to getting my lab up and running hopefully with some of those bio blazers.
Yeah, that would be cool.
And uh yeah, just things keep coming up so keep looking at my website.
I'm I'll keep people posted there.
When are you leaving for Germany?
I'm leaving on Friday evening.
This Friday.
Yeah.
Okay.
And I'll be back May first.
But they want me to go again in May and then at the end of May I please go ahead and go to Mexico.
So Well I was thinking, you know, you might be able to listen to the show before you go, but hey this is the internet.
You're in Germany, you can listen to it in Germany.
That's right.
So what am I thinking?
Yeah.
That's the beauty of it.
When is it on?
It'll go up Sunday night at around nine o'clock Eastern time.
And then it stays up, you know, as a real audio file twenty four hours a day, seven days a week you just go onto the website and click on the link and uh real audio will start and you can listen to the program anywhere in the world.
Holoworld dot com.
Yeah.
And there's three years of programs on there as well with a lot of different people involved with philography.
So if you ever have a chance to sit back with a cup of coffee or a cup of tea when you're home some night want to hear what some of the other people have said over the last three years.
Uh you know Oh that's wonderful.
Well I congratulate you on what you're doing.
I think it's it's really remarkable.
Yeah, well you're doing remarkable work too so as long as we all keep doing what we're doing, we'll keep moving ahead.
I think so.
Yeah.
Well thank you very much for being on the show.
You're welcome and uh give Lillian a kiss from me.
I certainly do.
And I'll get a chance to meet both of you once again when I come into New York.
Yes, absolutely.
Okay give a little notice if you can.
And you're welcome to the lab.
All right.
Take care.
Bye bye bye.